CONDUCTED JUST BEFORE HE WENT ON
STAGE FOR THIS RALLY.
LET'S WATCH.
MR. PRESIDENT, WORD BROKE LATE
TODAY, EARLY THIS EVENING THAT
THERE MIGHT BE SOME TENTATIVE
DEAL STRUCK TO AVERT A
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US?
>> President Trump: I CAN TELL
YOU A LOT OF THINGS HAVE CHANGED
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENED.
I CAN'T GO INTO THE EXACT DEAL.
I JUST HEARD IT VERY QUICKLY
COMING OVER TO SEE YOU.
IT'S BETWEEN THE DEAL AND YOU
AND I HAD TO CHOOSE YOU.
I HAD NO CHOICE IN A VERY HAPPY
I DID.
WE WERE ARE TALKING AND WE WILL
SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> Laura: THERE IS AN OPPOSING
RALLY KIND OF GOING ON THIS THE
SAME TIME AS THIS RALLY.
BETO O'ROURKE, YOUNG KIND OF
UP-AND-COMER THEY SAY IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
HE SAYS THAT WALL IS REALLY
ABOUT HATE AND RACISM.
TO THAT, YOU SAY WHAT?
>> President Trump: VERY FEW
PEOPLE SHOWED UP TO HIS RALLY.
THIS PLACE IS PACKED WITH
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OUTSIDE.
I GUESS HE CHALLENGED US TO AN
EVENT, SO MAYBE THIS MEANS HE'S
GOING TO HAVE TO DROP OUT OF THE
RACE BECAUSE THIS WAS NOT A GOOD
SITUATION FOR HIM.
I DON'T KNOW WHY HE DIDN'T.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
ANYTHING OTHER THAN SAFETY FOR
THE AMERICANS, SAFETY FOR OUR
PEOPLE, SAFETY FOR OUR COUNTRY.
AND A WALL IS A VERY GOOD THING,
NOT A BAD THING.
IT'S A MORAL THING, TO PUT IT IN
THE OPPOSITE TERMS.
WE DON'T EVEN SAY BUILD THE WALL
ANYMORE.
WE SAY FINISH THE WALL BECAUSE
WE BUILT A LOT AND WE ARE
RENOVATING A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF STUFF THAT WAS REALLY IN BAD
SHAPE BUT IT HAD GOOD STRUCTURE.
SO WE ARE SAYING FINISH THE
WALL.
WALLS ARE VERY IMPORTANT.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE IT, ALL THE
TECHNOLOGY, LAURA, ALL THE
DRONES THEY HAVE LYING AROUND SO
NICELY UP IN THE AIR, THEY DON'T
MEAN A THING.
>> Laura: WHAT ABOUT THE
BORDER SHERIFFS, BORDER MAYORS,
THEY SAY NO, WE DON'T NEED A
WALL.
WE ARE SAY.
THEY WERE CHALLENGING SOME OF
YOUR STATISTICS ON EL PASO EVEN
THOUGH WAR IS HEADED TERRIBLE
YEAR LAST YEAR FOR MURDERS.
>> President Trump: THOUGH
MURDERS ARE TREMENDOUS AND HORA
HORAS.
JUAREZ.
CRIME WAS VERY HIGH AND THEN THE
WALL GOT BUILT.
YOU SHOULD TALK ABOUT THE
SHERIFFS THAT AGREE WITH ME WERE
CHAIR LIKE 90% OF THE SHERIFFS
IN THE COUNTRY, MAYBE ALL OF
THEM.
>> Laura: WERE GOING TO REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF DETENTION BEDS.
WHAT WAS THAT ABOUT?
>> President Trump: IT MEANS
YOU DON'T DETAIN PEOPLE WHO ARE
VERY DANGEROUS.
YOU HAVE TO PUT THEM OUT INTO
OUR SOCIETY BECAUSE OUR LAWS ARE
SO BAD IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT
HAPPENED AND WHAT'S BEEN PASSED
OVER THE YEARS IN CONGRESS, IT'S
A SHAME.
IT'S A DISGRACE.
THAT MEANS WE CAN'T JUST PUT
THEM BACK INTO MEXICO OR WHERE
THEY CAME.
WE HAVE TO PUT THEM BACK IN OUR
SOCIETY AND IN SOME CASES THEY
ARE STONE COLD CRIMINALS.
WE CAN'T DO THAT.
>> Laura: ANOTHER GOOD PIECE
OF ECONOMIC NEWS CAME OUT TODAY.
PERSONAL CONFIDENCE IN THE
ECONOMY IS AT A 16 YEAR HIGH.
WHY ARE SO MANY MILLENNIALS
GRAVITATING IN SOME POLLS TOWARD
SOCIALISM OVER CAPITALISM?
WHAT CAN YOU DO TO REINVIGORATE
THEIR UNDERSTANDING OF THE FREE
MARKET?
>> President Trump: NUMBER
ONE, THEY ARE YOUNG.
THEY ARE IDEALISTIC IF YOU CALL
IT IDEALISTIC.
I THINK CAPITALISM IS MORE OF AN
IDEAL.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE POLL
NUMBERS COMING LOOK AT THE KIND
OF NUMBERS THAT WE HAVE, IT'S
BEEN GREAT.
I HIT MY ALL-TIME HIGH TODAY.
52%.
THAT'S WITH ONLY BAD STORIES
BECAUSE THE PRESS ONLY GIVES ME
BAD STORIES.
YOU TREAT ME FAIRLY.
>> Laura: WHEN YOU -- WERE YOU
SURPRISED WHEN SOME DEMOCRATS
DIDN'T STAND UP WHEN YOU ASKED
AT THE STATE OF THE UNIT ABOUT
SOCIALISM.
>> President Trump: THAT'S WHY
THEY'RE COMING FROM.
WHEN I SEE SOME OF THE
RESPONSES, WHEN I SEE SOME OF
THE STATEMENTS MADE BY
CONGRESSMEN AND WOMEN, I SAY I
WAS LIVING IN THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA?
WE HAVE A COUNTRY THAT'S DOING
THE BEST IT'S EVER DONE.
WE ARE JUST LAPPING THE WORLD.
IT USED TO BE LIKE WE WERE A
SECOND SISTER TO CHINA.
NOW CHINA IS LOOKING UP TO AUST.
WE ARE DOING SO WELL.
IN OTHER COUNTRIES ARE NOT DOING
WELL.
IT MAKES IT TOUGHER FOR US IN A
CERTAIN WAY BECAUSE WE DO
BUSINESS WITH OTHER COUNTRIES.
BUT WE ARE SETTING RECORDS IN SO
MANY WAYS, INCLUDING RECORDS,
RECORD UNEMPLOYMENT, IN A
POSITIVE WAY.
>> Laura: THEY SAY OBAMA
STARTED IT AND THEN THEY SAY
THERE'S ECONOMIC INEQUALITY.
THAT'S THE NEW BUZZWORD.
YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR IT A LOT.
THE YOUNG FRESHMAN CONGRESSMAN.
SOME OF THE CANDIDATES ARE
REALLY GRAVITATING TOWARD IT.
>> President Trump:
PRESIDENT OBAMA, YOU LOOK AT HIS
LAST MONTHS AND WHAT HAPPENED
THE FIRST MONTH COMING INTO MY
TERM, THEY WERE VERY LOW, THE
NUMBERS, GDP LUMBERS AND
EVERYTHING ELSE.
IF I WOULD'VE STAYED WITH THOSE
NUMBERS, WE WOULD'VE HAD IN THE
ECONOMY THAT WOULD BE GOING IN
REVERSE.
WE GOT RID OF UNNECESSARY
REGULATIONS, THE BIGGEST TAX CUT
WE'VE EVER DONE.
WE OPEN UP THE OIL.
WHERE THE LARGEST OIL EXPORTER.
WE ARE THE LARGEST OIL AND GAS
IN THE WORLD RIGHT NOW.
NOBODY THOUGHT THAT WAS POSSIBLE
THIS QUICKLY.
WE OPENED UP OUR COUNTRY.
WE ARE LETTING PEOPLE WORK
AGAIN.
WE HAVE MORE PEOPLE WORKING
TODAY, ALMOST 160 MILLION
PEOPLE.
WE ARE MORE PEOPLE WORKING TODAY
THAN I'VE EVER WORKED IN THE
UNITED STATES.
IT'S GREAT.
>> Laura: WE DIDN'T HAVE SOME
PEOPLE STAND FOR THAT AT THE
STATE OF THE UNION.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU?
I GOT LOTS OF TEXTS.
THEY ARE TRYING TO PARALYZE OUR
ECONOMY WITH INVESTIGATIONS,
OVERSIGHT, YOU'RE GETTING
HAMMERED WITH REQUESTS FOR
DOCUMENTS AND SO FORTH WHICH IS
PART OF THE OVERSIGHT.
WHAT'S GOING ON THERE?
>> President Trump: WHAT
HAPPENED TO ME SHOULD NEVER BE
ALLOWED TO HAPPEN TO ANOTHER
PRESIDENT WITH INVESTIGATIONS ON
THINGS THAT NEVER TOOK PLACE,
LIKE RUSSIA.
THE RUSSIA COLLUSION DELUSION WE
CALL IT.
I CALL IT A HOAX.
IN FACT, IT WAS VERY NICE.
RICHARD BURR THE OTHER DAY CAME
OUT AFTER ALMOST TWO YEARS OF
INVESTIGATION, THEY FOUND
ABSOLUTELY NO COLLUSION BETWEEN
TRUMP AND THE RUSSIA, WHICH I
COULD'VE TOLD A LOT OF PEOPLE
AND WHICH I HAVE BEEN SAYING TO
A LOT OF PEOPLE.
THIS IS NEVER HAPPENED.
THE DEMOCRATS KNOW IT'S A HOAX.
IT'S A POLITICAL GAME.
NOW THE RUSSIA THING IS DEAD AND
THEY SAY WELL, WE ARE GOING TO
LOOK AT EVERY COMPANY THAT
DONALD TRUMP WAS EVER -- THEY
DON'T HAVE ANY INFORMATION.
WERE GOING TO LOOK AT EVERY
COMPANY THAT DONALD TRUMP WAS
EVER INVOLVED IN.
I DID GREAT.
I MADE A LOT OF MONEY.
NOW THEY WANT TO GO BACK AND
INVESTIGATE EVERY COMPANY.
WE HAVE AND I THINK 79 DIFFERENT
LETTERS FROM DIFFERENT
COMMITTEES.
>> Laura: HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
RESPOND TO THESE LETTERS?
>> President Trump: FOR THE
MOST PART, THEY ARE CONFLICTED.
I GOT ONE FROM POCAHONTAS TODAY
WERE IT SAID THAT DONALD TRUMP,
WE WANT TO INVESTIGATE SOME
COMPANY, IT'S SO DISGRACEFUL.
I SAID JUST WRITE HER BACK AND
SAY SHE'S GOT A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST, OKAY?
SHE SHOULD FOCUS MORE ON HER
HERITAGE AND NOT BEING ASHAMED
OF WHAT SHE IS.
SHE SHOULD REALLY FOCUS ON
OURSELVES.
WE'VE GOTTEN LETTERS, LAUREL,
FROM SO MANY COMMITTEES.
I DIDN'T KNOW WE HAD SO MANY
COMMITTEES.
I THINK IT'S UP TO 79 LETTERS.
THIS IS BASED ON NO INFORMATION
OF ANY WRONGDOING BECAUSE I'M A
VERY STRAIGHT PERSON.
SO WE WENT THROUGH THIS WHOLE
RUSSIAN HOAX.
NOBODY HAS EVER DONE WHAT I DID
WHERE I WAS HIT WITH THIS.
THINK OF THIS.
HIT WITH IT AND WE PROBABLY HAVE
THE GREATEST FIRST TWO YEARS OF
ANY PRESIDENT IN OUR HISTORY IN
TERMS OF WHAT WE'VE ACCOMPLISHED
WITH EMPLOYMENT, WITH GDP, WITH
EVERYTHING.
COMPANIES ARE MOVING BACK INTO
OUR COUNTRY WHICH IS ONE OF THE
GREAT STATS.
>> Laura: AFRICAN-AMERICANS IN
THIS COUNTRY, WHAT WOULD YOU SAY
TO THE YOUNG AFRICAN-AMERICAN
TODAY IN VIRGINIA WHO IS SEEING
THE TURMOIL IN THAT STATE AND
WANTS TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THEIR
RACE ISSUE IS PUMMELING US ON
ALL SIDES.
>> President Trump: TERRIBLE
SITUATIONS.
I THINK THE REPUBLICANS, THEY DO
WELL IN VIRGINIA, A LOT OF
THINGS ARE HAPPENING IN
VIRGINIA.
I DIDN'T CAMPAIGN IN VIRGINIA
BECAUSE I WAS TOLD THAT A
REPUBLICAN --
>> Laura: NOT MUCH, A FEW
STOPS.
>> President Trump: VIRTUALLY
NOT.
LOOK AT THE NUMBERS, WHY AREN'T
I THERE?
THEY SORT OF ASSUMED IT'S A
DEMOCRAT STATE AND AS YOU KNOW I
DID VERY WELL THERE WITHOUT
HAVING GONE.
I THINK VIRGINIA IS READY TO
FLIP OVER TO SOMETHING AND I
WILL TELL YOU AFRICAN-AMERICANS
ARE COMING TO THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY LIKE NOBODY CAN BELIEVE.
A LOT OF THINGS ARE HAPPENING.
A LOT OF VERY POSITIVE THINGS.
>> Laura: SHOULD NORTHAM
RESIGN?
>> President Trump: I WATCHED
HIS NEWS CONFERENCE.
IT WAS PRETTY SAD.
LET THEM FIGURE OUT WHAT TO DO,
BUT I FELT ACTUALLY -- I FELT
SORRY FOR HIS WIFE AND HIS WIFE
SAVED HIM FROM DOING, AS YOU
KNOW, MICHAEL JACKSON.
HE WAS GOING TO TRY TO IMITATE
MICHAEL JACKSON WITH THE
MOONWALK.
NOBODY CAN IMITATE MICHAEL WITH
THE MOONWALK.
THIS WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN PRETTY.
YOU AND THAT COUPLE SECONDS OF